I feel a frustration a constant whisper
that I am no closer to achieving my
dreams mister that's Shelley beautiful
isn't he just how old are you then old
enough to know why you are asking from
16
when I met you I felt alive come away
with me oh you're really involved with
that whole monk I have a fire in my soul
and I will no longer allow you or anyone
else to contain it
who amongst you has ever wondered if the
dead could return to life is that really
possible
reanimation we've been invited to Geneva
by Lord Byron would you like to draw in
the polymers okay I have no qualms with
you becoming lovers you wished you were
someone else
I no longer see the world and it's works
they before appeared to me and men
appear to me as monster we are each to
write a ghost story it's a competition
the woman he's not intelligent enough to
form ideas of her own that's folly you
miss Ordway and have the chance to prove
me wrong don't you recognize Victor
Frankenstein this is no ghost story it
chilled me to the bone you must get your
story published marry curious subject
matter for young lady are you suggesting
the work belongs to mr. shell it is my
story
new dare question a woman's ability to
experience loss betrayal death if I have
not learned to fight through the anguish
I would not about this voice my choices
made me who I am
you